Michael Porter Jr shooting a lot of jump
shots threes and he can't get it going
he's putting Coach Moore in a very tough
spot now you go out there and you win
game three
so never hit the panic button off of off
a win
but Michael Porter Jr is going to have
to play better we spoke about it earlier
in this series or at the beginning of
the series or leading up to or maybe a
couple series ago whatever Michael
Porter defensively not the strongest
Defender I will say I I've noticed him
giving more effort on the defensive end
you can appreciate that that was One Max
truce three max true slipped out kcp ran
to help when he ran to help Max truce
was open they kicked the max struce you
have Michael Porter Jr in the corner
like you got to make that next rotation
Michael Porter Jr doesn't make the next
rotation kcp comes running back from
helping to get back to Max truce when
you should get the next rotation from
Michael Porter Jr
he comes running back max truce lines it
up now doesn't cost you yesterday
but all of a sudden Max true see that
one go in which he did but then he catch
a rhythm off that and those are the type
of plays that can cost you